[Musique]
sur France 24 il y a 10 ans le 20
novembre 2012 le M23 prenait le contrôle
de Goma capitale du Nord qui vous en RDC
10 ans plus tard c'est même rebelles
sont une nouvelle fois aux portes de la
ville cette guerre a perturbé d'ailleurs
le Sommet de la Francophonie ce week-end
ou sont apparus les tensions entre
Congolais et rwandais le Premier
ministre congolais a refusé de poser sur
la photo de famille à côté de Paul
Kagame la délégation congolaise a
d'ailleurs accusé la secrétaire général
de l'organisation de la Francophonie
louise Mushikiwabo de prendre fêter
cause pour le Rwanda 200 000 congolais
ont dû fuir une nouvelle fois ce lundi
s'ouvre un aérobie au Kenya une nouvelle
tentative de discussion médiation
l'ancien président kenyan il y aura
Kenyatta et le facilitateur de la
communauté d'Afrique de l'Est pour la
paix en RDC alors comment expliquer que
le M23 soit une nouvelle fois aux portes
de Goma les rebelles seront-ils la ville
une nouvelle fois qu'il est soutient
quels sont finalement les espoirs de
paix dans cette région alors que
s'ouvrent aujourd'hui c'est pour parler
à nairobie au Kenya et bien on en débat
avec mes invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés pierre Boisselet bonsoir vous
êtes coordinateur des recherches sur la
violence à l'Institut congolais de
recherche et bouteilles c'est une
structure partenaire recherche du groupe
d'études sur le Congo à l'université de
New York bienvenue à vous en face de
vous Roland courtier bonsoir vous êtes
géographe professeur il mérite à
l'Université Paris 1 Panthéon Sorbonne
bienvenue à vous également avec nous
aussi Jean-Claude Félix chicaya bonsoir
chercheur pour l'Institut de prospective
et sécurité en Europe bienvenue nous
avons par Skype de Kinshasa Patrick
mouya porte-parole du gouvernement de
RDC ministre de la Communication et des
Médias de RDC bonsoir à vous et
bienvenue
bonsoir à tous nous avons également par
Skype de Suède Aloïs tegera historien
bonsoir à vous
bonsoir avant de démarrer ce débat je
voudrais que écouter justement un
certain nombre de témoins et congolais
qui fuient leur village à l'arrivée du
M23 à Goma
nous craignons maintenant que les
rebelles arrivent ici j'avais fui mon
village mais en arrivant à kibomba il y
avait aussi beaucoup de coups de feu et
à la fin je me suis retrouvé ici mais
avant-hier des soldats ont ouvert le feu
ici aussi et on a encore fui vers Goma
nous sommes revenus et c'est la
souffrance je suis là mais je n'ai nulle
part où dormir
[Musique]
sur la jambe droite suite aux éclats
a essayé de m'emmener à l'hôpital
mais personne ne voulait me soigner car
les infirmiers étaient aussi en train de
fuir
[Musique]
et là je suis en train de construire
pour les enfants j'ai préféré qu'il soit
juste à côté de moi pour qu'en cas
d'attaque nous puissions fuir tous
ensemble
congolais qui ont déjà dû fuir la région
ça s'est passé il y a 10 ans on s'est
retrouvé exactement avec les M23 qui
pour le coup ont pris Goma est-ce que
c'est la peur qui règne aujourd'hui à
Goma est-ce que finalement on est
exactement le même scénario disant après
alors l'histoire le dira pour l'instant
la ville est pas prise je pense pas que
ce soit le scénario le plus probable
mais évidemment cette prise de Goma il y
a très exactement 10 ans et dans toutes
les têtes à Goma et qui évidemment une
psychose une crainte véritable que ça
que ça arrive il sent combien de
kilomètres une vingtaine a priori donc
effectivement la menace est très proche
et pourquoi est-ce que vous dites qu'a
priori ça ne va pas se reproduire alors
bon ce sont deux mots
c'est un peu compliqué mais disons que
en 2012 ça a été un petit peu le début
de la fin pour pouvoir y revenir en
détail en tout cas vous dites ils ne
sont pas forcément ils ne vont peut-être
pas prendre la ville Patrick mouya parce
que vous êtes le porte-parole du
gouvernement du RDC est-ce que vous
pouvez nous confirmer ces informations
justement est-ce qu'effectivement les
rebelles sont à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de Goma et vous est-ce que
vous pensez qu'ils vont prendre la ville
les agressions vous le dire il faut
qu'on arrive à parler de l'armée
rwandaise de manière claire on va en
parler là j'ai vraiment déjà sur le
constat sur où se trouve le
les forces sont localisés à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de Goma
évidemment et les dispositifs est en
place de forces armées pour que cela
n'arrive pas et je crois que dans le
jour qui viennent parce qu'il y a les
déploiement de la France régionale qui
va commencer ce n'est pas évident qui
pourront atteindre la ville mais on ne
sait jamais parce que la stratégie de la
violence clairement choisie par les
Rwanda n'a visiblement pas de limite au
regard même de tout ce que vous avez
montré dans vos images tout à l'heure
ces femmes ces hommes ces jeunes enfants
qui sont obligés d'aérer dans leur
propre pays parce que simplement il y a
des appétits économiques dans la vie
c'est le temps que cela s'arrête et
c'est les messages que nous avons passé
hier à l'occasion du Sommet de la
Francophonie où nous avons participé
avec le Premier ministre chef du
gouvernement on va revenir justement sur
parce qu'effectivement le combo la RDC
accuse le Rwanda d'être derrière le M23
un mot d'abord Roland courtier justement
sur cette force du M23 pour ceux qui
nous regardent qui connaissent pas bien
l'actualité en RDC qui sont-ils ces
rebelles on parle d'une rébellion à
majorité Tutsi il y en a il y a un
certain nombre de chefs toutes si
congolais dont d'ailleurs il y en a un
qui a même été condamné par la CPI c'est
ça le M23 aujourd'hui
que la résurgence d'un mouvement déjà
ancien qui s'est manifesté on vient de
le dire il y a déjà 10 ans avec la prise
de Goma mais pour comprendre ce
phénomène il faut remonter plus loin
c'est toute la crise de cette région des
grands lacs qui a de multiples facteurs
structurels sur lesquels j'aimerais tout
à l'heure dire quelques mots et le M23
est sorti des tensions entre la RDC et
des gros problèmes et le Rwanda
M23 parce que ce mouvement est né en
réaction contre la non-application d'un
accord qui avait été signé le
23 mars je crois
et
1900 2009 pardon et donc comme les
clauses de cet accord n'avait pas été
respecté en particulier les anciens
rebelles n'ont pas été réintégrés
correctement dans l'armée congolaise ou
non pas été réinséré correctement dans
la société civile ils ont pris les armes
et ce sont des mouvements qui
reviendrent régulièrement la profondeur
historique joue un rôle considérable et
on doit remonter beaucoup plus loin que
2012 pour comprendre fondamentalement
les raisons de cette crise beaucoup plus
loin qu'il y a 10 ans Jean-Claude Félix
chicaya en quoi cette région est telle
stratégique aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
une situation pas aussi cycique mais
quand même ça a été dit plusieurs fois
il faut revenir plusieurs décennies en
arrière sur ce fameux groupe M23 il y en
a une vingtaine d'autres qui
malheureusement sont pas les seuls ils
ne sont pas les seuls et ils sont tous
illégitimes et ont tous pour objectif de
balkaniser pas seulement l'est du Congo
mais le combo lui-même et le et le
déstabiliser avec des soutiens qui
viennent parfois du Rwanda et
d'autrefois de longand et autres donc
c'est bien une situation pas seulement
liée à la souveraineté que défend
justement comme ça a été dit par le
porte-parole bec et ongles le le RDC et
elle ne doit pas céder un seul pouce
parce que les les personnes la personne
qui était sur son lit tout à l'heure une
dame et les Congolais ont dans leur fond
d'écran et dans leur histoire cette
histoire congolaise avec ce lac qui vous
qui
représente pas seulement une frontière
naturelle mais gorgée de matière
première qui sont absolument les outils
et les instruments idéologiques et qui
donne fin et soif à un peuple qui veut
vivre librement et que la souveraineté
de la RDC soit donc respecter il est
bien pour cela que le le gouvernement de
RDC comme il le fait actuellement ça
peut être une situation négociée sur le
plan politique on va venir
partir pour malheureusement vers le pire
on le souhaite pas pour que la
souveraineté du Rwanda de RDC soit donc
eux maintenu et repousser le M23 et ceux
qui soutiennent qui soutiennent ce
groupe et d'autres et ce qui est en fond
d'écran on peut dire sans extérieur le
cobalt à 80% la raison et et plein
d'autres donc le Congo donc les matières
les premières c'est ça qui est
potentiellement des pays les plus riches
mais malheureusement cette géostratégie
c'est Jo et c'est géopolitique intéresse
et malheureusement donc des voisins
viennent
mes voisins c'est à dire
erwanais
parce que tout à l'heure c'est vrai
qu'on peut dire que le
RDC dit de manière légitime qu'ils sont
qu'ils sont soutenus mais c'est pas
seulement la RDC les les référents et
les experts américains les experts
onusiens l'Union africaine serait bien
d'ailleurs qu'elle fasse montre un peu
plus de de de en tout cas prendre à une
position parce que la situation est
paroxystique puisque vous êtes historien
vous avez longtemps vécu à Goma est-ce
que finalement cette guerre existerait
sans un soutien rwandais sans une
intervention des Ougandais un peu ce que
vient de dire Jean-Claude félicitaillard
c'est-à-dire que finalement ce sont les
puissances autour qui finalement
fomentent le conflit
merci pour la parole et en fait je suis
en visite en Suède mais je travaille à
Goma à pour l'Institute une institut de
recherche qui travaille à Gomma depuis à
peu près 25 ans
pour la question que vous posez je pense
qu'en fait le problème de Bagna Wanda a
décidé du Congo n'est pas un problème
d'hier même si on peut remonter
l'histoire de M23
dans les années 2004 car le CNDP avait
commencé et puis
M23 en 2012 mais quand même le problème
de Bagnol dans l'Est du Congo c'est un
problème qui est très très ancien et à
mon avis je pense aussi
le racine du mal c'est pour moi
la mauvaise gestion du patrimoine Bagnac
par la colonisation belge
oui tout à fait parce que si on ne
remonte pas loin on ne comprend pas
d'abord
les cartographes les cartographes belges
le premier qui a parlé des tribus à
l'instit du Congo il parlait de batucci
entre parenthèses liées au retour de
retour
et le deuxième qui a parlé de manière
Rwanda c'est bon enceinte qui disait ok
il y a des bagnoles
mais le même bon à 54 quand il fait la
cartographie des ethnies de chez vous il
a au milieu
on retrouve que ce soit sur les réseaux
sociaux même aussi dans les débats ou
mes compatriotes peuvent venir écoute
montrez-moi où se trouve ici la carte du
Congo déjà c'était
stigmatisation existe déjà avant la
colonisation maintenant après la
colonisation
j'ose dire que en fait beaucoup de nos
locaux nausées
une histoire de vivre de mal vivre
ensemble à Kinshasa et en réalité je
pense que le problème de
stimatisation de Bagnes
ne commence pas
en 2012 ça commence bien avant alors
justement
je voulais vous retrouver à nouveau
Patrick mouya parce que vous parliez
vous de l'implication
du Rwanda alors j'ai lu que les experts
c'est ce que je disais un peu Félix
chicaya à l'instant les experts de l'ONU
et les baromètres sécurité du Kivu dans
leur rapport enduit en juillet affirme
détenir des preuves de l'implication du
Rwanda dans ce conflit alors le Rwanda
ni et accuse au contraire d'être de
l'armée congolaise d'être l'Allier des
Forces démocratiques de libération du
Rwanda donc quel est quel est votre
discours pour vous ce conflit et fomenté
par Kigali
écoutez il y a un effet historiques qui
peuvent témoigner et que le kiki Galli
était derrière le RCD Goma derrière les
scènes d'épée derrière les M23 parce
qu'il éclaire que dans leur stratégie de
continuer les pillages à l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo il faut
toujours avoir des paravents je dois
rappeler que le M23 était défait et
totalement désarmé depuis 2013 comment
vous pouvez penser que 10 ans plus tard
il puisse se réorganiser et avoir une
puissance des feux que le secrétaire
général des Nations unies reconnais il
dit c'est une armée régulière qui combat
en reconnaissant l'aveu de la mission
qui n'était pas en mesure de combattre
ces mouvements
qui opère il est discours
mensongés portés par Kigali porte
essentiellement sur deux points d'abord
un discours ségrégationniste qui parle
de nos communautés d'outils parce qu'il
prend il prétendent les protéger en
tuant et en faisant déplacer plusieurs
milliers de personnes vous avez vu le
drame et puis sur la question des œuvres
de l'air les FDR menacent d'abord
menacent d'abord le population
congolaise l'ère télé aujourd'hui 24 28
ans plus tard après les Jeux de Citroën
ne représente pas une véritable menace
pour la sécurité des Kigali au contraire
nous nous avons combattu des êtres vous
ne serez pas en mesure aujourd'hui de
donner le seul nom d'un chef aide FDR
connu et que le groupe résiduel qui
reste nous continuons de le combattre
dans les cas de la force régionale ils
seront aussi la cible de ces combats et
donc nous nous considérons que les vrais
mobiles de ces combats il est économique
le Rwandais devait être en mesure
d'arrêter cette forme de de combat pour
que nous puissions dans la paix comme le
président de la République le port
depuis son arrivée à la tête de ces pays
reconstruire la région de grand lacs et
voir dans quelle mesure nous pourrons
consolider les échanges entre les
différentes communautés les différents
pays et donc venir aujourd'hui brandir
la question des effets de l'air c'est
mentir à l'histoire parce que les êtres
de leurs noms en aucun cas attaqué des
territoires rondé et il ne se rend pas
en mesure de le faire et pourtant nous
nous payons les prix vous voyez
vous-même la catastrophe humanitaire qui
se vit dans cette partie de notre vie
FDLR pour bien préciser force
démocratique de libération du Rwanda qui
est un groupe rebelle Hutu effectivement
le Rwanda accuse RDC d'être l'Allier de
ce groupe rebelle pour redonner un peu
de contexte pierre Boisselet peut-être
que vous réagir ce que vient de dire le
porte-parole de RDC est-ce
qu'effectivement il n'y a que le Rwanda
qui soit responsable alors je pense
qu'il y a bon c'est une grande partie de
l'histoire
la responsabilité du Rwanda existe et on
l'a dit vous l'avez rappelé etc je pense
que par ailleurs
il y a aussi une partie du problème qui
tient à la faiblesse de l'armée
congolaise plus largement des
institutions congolaises mais en
l'occurrence
puisqu'on parle du conflit et là
actuellement de l'armée congolaise on
sait qu'elle a un grand nombre de
difficultés structurelles qui sont liées
à quoi parce que j'ai vu qu'il y avait
130 000 hommes dans cette armée et qu'il
y a 1000 rebelles du M23 c'est à peu
près ça la proportion
c'est un chiffre théorique officiel on
sait que il y a une grande partie des
effectifs officiels qui ne sont pas en
fait présents sur le terrain on sait
qu'il y a des gros problèmes de gestion
de la zone de la chaîne de dépenses de
la corruption des problèmes de moyens de
gestion des équipements enfin la liste
est
très longue vous pouvez peut-être réagir
justement
à Kinshasa ce que vient de dire
justement pierre boissolès qui a pas un
problème quand même de déficit de l'État
congolais dans cette région et même
peut-être de problèmes liés à l'armée
congolaise elle-même
je crois qu'il y a il y a ici il faut
qu'on soit en mesure de le reconnaître
que notre armée aujourd'hui souffre
justement parce que de parler passé nous
sommes passés par différents processus
des brassages des mixages et donc sage
il y a eu des éléments infiltrés qui
régulièrement bottes mal la stratégie
des défenses du pays même la guerre
actuelle le mobile serait à la fin de
prendre ceux qui sont considérés
aujourd'hui comme des terroristes les
réintégrer l'armée c'est l'une des
revendications principales d'ailleurs de
certains aujourd'hui il faut reconnaître
qu'il y a évidemment des difficultés
structurelles mais nous sommes en train
de difficultés de votre armée justement
et les difficultés structurelles c'est
d'abord les passes les brassages et les
mixages que j'ai relevé tout à l'heure
et puis c'était volonté permanente de
garder cette partie en conflit parce que
bien au-delà de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui le Rwanda toujours gardé de
proxy parce que le jour où cette partie
sera stabilisée nous mettrons fin à tous
ces réseaux justement économiques de
pillage dont d'ailleurs l'un des pas de
protagoniste a été sanctionné par les
départements américains aujourd'hui il
existe une loi de programmation au
niveau de l'armée aujourd'hui il y a un
haut commandement militaire qui a été à
peine nommé il y a un mois et demi et
nous faisons justement face à ces
guerres parce que la volonté c'est de ne
pas nous laisser de manière sereine
reconstruire notre armée qui sert à
notre appareil de défense et qui sera
dissuasif vis-à-vis de toutes ces
intentions bien connues expansionnistes
du Rwanda et donc nous nous
reconnaissons qu'il y a ces travail
qu'il faut faire nous y travaillons et
nous pensons que si nous avons la
sérénité qu'il faut nous serons à mesure
de relever les défis de notre armée
c'est pas une fatalité des défis que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui justement
sur l'armée congolaise
sur l'armée congolaise je n'ai pas grand
chose de particuliers à dire mais ce que
je constate c'est que et ça c'est
important l'histoire se répète
malheureusement l'histoire bégaye parce
que on n'a jamais réussi depuis un
siècle et en tout cas dans les dernières
décennies résoudre des problèmes de fond
tes problèmes structuros et en
particulier on est dans une zone de très
forte tension démographique et de
pression qui viennent de l'Est vers
l'Ouest c'est à dire du Rwanda
essentiellement vers le Congo et ça ça
ne date pas d'aujourd'hui ça date il y a
100 ans ou plus et à l'époque coloniale
déjà les Belges avaient organisé une
migration des zones très peuplées du
Rwanda vers l'Est du Congo où on avait
besoin de main d'oeuvre et le mouvement
n'a cessé depuis lors et cette pression
est considérable parce que au Rwanda
nous avons aujourd'hui une densité de
population d'environ 500 habitants en
kilomètres carrés
c'est trop et donc quand il y a un
trop-plein quelque part on va vers des
zones moins dans ces moins peuplées et
c'est tout ce mouvement qui touche en
particulier les éleveurs Tutsis qui
s'est développé sur l'est du Congo et
qui crée des tensions et on a évoqué les
tensions à l'intérieur de l'armée mais
fondamentalement il y a ces tensions
très fortes entre ceux qu'on a appelé
les étrangers et les autochtones et tant
qu'on n'aura pas résolu ce problème
fondamental qui est lié à la pression
démographique et à cette poussée qui
vient du Rwanda et bien on n'arrivera
pas à résoudre durablement les problèmes
de la région Jean-Claude fait chicaya le
Sommet de la Francophonie ce weekend a
été perturbé par justement ce conflit
dans le Nord qui vous avec le M23 on a
vu que le premier ministre d'abord le
président de leur décès a refusé de s'y
rendre parce qu'il y avait Paul Kagame
et le Premier ministre a refusé de
figurer sur la photo avec le président
rwandais Emmanuel Macron a fait le va et
vient manifestement entre le Premier
ministre de RDC et Kagame on ne se parle
pas en fait
ce qui démontre ce que démonte cette
épisode en fin de sommet
de l'OIF si on l'appelle encore comme
cela c'est à dire que la fraise voilà la
présidence de l'ancienne qui est
ancienne ministre des Affaires
étrangères rwandaise qui connaît bien
tout ce qu'on vient de dire sur le plan
multifactoriel et structurel et pas
seulement lié à l'armée de la RDC est
lié au problème structurant RDC mais
aussi à l'extérieur dans l'air de la RDC
donc c'est bien des problèmes multi
factorielle mais sur le plan régional
donc ce que ce que ce que a essayé de
faire monsieur Macron et d'autres c'est
d'aller d'osciller entre là et l'autre
et on peut voir que la la position de de
la RDC c'était de durcir le ton sur
négociant une négociation politique qui
malheureusement le Rwanda traîne des
pieds pour demander parce qu'il a un
certain pouvoir et un pouvoir certain
sur le M23 de sortir de sortir des
terrains sur lesquels il arrive il ne
cesse arriver pour se rendre vers Goma
avec une cohorte de de de souffrance de
crimes de viol et autres à l'égard à
l'encontre des des populations donc
c'est une situation comme elle a été dit
par
l'historien et d'autres personnes qui
c'est un fond d'écran c'est un fond
d'écran qu'à l'intérieur de tous les
Congolais pas seulement dans l'Est du
Congo mais un peu partout donc là ça
commence à se ressentir sur le plan
national comme une souveraineté qui est
complètement ébrégée chacun sait au
Congo qui a tout un pays à travailler
pour un renouveau structurel national
comme ça a été dit et notamment l'armée
où il y a à l'intérieur plein de
problèmes à régler et qui bien sûr on
dirait Cochet visible sur et qui
représente parfois des failles dans
lesquelles ces rebelles malheureusement
soutenus peuvent entrer malheureusement
rentrer Patrick mouya ce Sommet de la
Francophonie finalement vous vous en
feriez quel bilan parce que
effectivement de ne pas souhaiter être
sur la photo avec Paul Kagame on a bien
vu qu'il y a eu des fortes tensions
entre Congolais et rwandais à ce sommet
qui était censé être un sommet de la
Francophonie
bon écoutez nous appartenons tout ça et
même famille qui s'appelle la
francophonie et d'ailleurs nous
réfléchissons sur l'avenir de la
Francophonie nous pensons qu'il doit y
avoir des instances pour régler des
problèmes entre les deux États membres
ici il faut rappeler que nous sommes
engagés dans trois processus le
processus d'aérobie le processus de
Luanda et puis la médiation portée par
les présidents français et c'est depuis
deux mois que nous sommes dans ces
différents processus depuis deux mois le
Rwanda s'engage à parler au M23 c'est le
langage diplomatique qui est tenu à ce
niveau là pour que M23 serait-il de ses
positions et rien ne se fait et donc
nous on ne peut pas continuer à venir
pour assister à des grandes messes de ce
type pendant que vous avez 300 000
compatriotes qui sont en dehors pendant
que vous savez que ce qui opère c'est
l'armée rwandaise qui opère il y a des
preuves qui vont la tester qui seront
publiés encore bientôt et que le
président rwandais ne cessant pas
particulièrement ému pour mettre fin à
cette situation et même de ce point de
vue l'attitude de la France devait être
encore plus plus résolu et plus forte
auprès du président Kagame pour que il
puisse donner l'ordre à ses hommes qui
opère en République démocratique du
Congo d'équité nous nous sommes venus
réitérer notre appartenance à cette
organisation régionale je dois rappeler
que nous sommes le premier pays de la
francophonie nous accueillons le jeu
nous attirons le jeu dans le jour qui
viennent et nous espérons que très
rapidement cette question sera résolue
c'est aussi cela être dans une famille
c'est aussi cela qui doit aujourd'hui
interpeller la France qui est le porteur
de la Francophonie pour que cette
question ces règles durablement parce
que c'est des populations francophones
qui payent le prix de plus d'un autre
pays francophone nous recevons de
pression populaire dans notre opinion
aujourd'hui les gens s'interrompre s'il
faut rester dans la francophonie ou
faire la quitter la réflexion n'est pas
encore à ce niveau là au niveau du
gouvernement mais la résolution de ces
problèmes grâce à l'implication de la
Francophonie pourra peut-être permettre
au congolais de penser que nous sommes
dans une famille où nous sommes
véritablement portés et que les valeurs
de solidarité prônées par la
francophonie se manifeste effectivement
alors ce lundi vous aviez référence
ouvre un aérobie donc au Kenya une
nouvelle tentative de discussion une
médiation l'ancien président kenyan
ouvert kenyata et le facilitateur de la
communauté d'Afrique de l'Est pour la
paix en RDC en parallèle l'actuel
président kenyan William roto est à
Kinshasa en RDC il a affirmé que la
force régionale est africaine avait pour
mandat d'imposer la paix au groupe
armées récalcitrant on va l'écouter
William roto et c'était donc à Kinshasa
nous nous sommes engagés dans le cadre
de la communauté d'Afrique de l'Est à
faire tout ce qui est nécessaire pour
soutenir son Excellence le Président
pour soutenir le gouvernement de la RDC
et son peuple
afin que nous puissions avoir la paix
dans ce pays
il est dans notre intérêt collectivement
et individuellement que nous ayons une
région en paix
et on va écouter maintenant moussafaki
qui est le président de la Commission de
l'Union africaine qui était au micro de
Mark peyrolman à Djerba justement en
Tunisie lors du Sommet de la
Francophonie
les discussions des Nairobi doivent
continuer
c'est au congolais bien entendu des
déterminer quels sont ceux qui vont
prendre part mais il est souhaitable
dans le cadre de la recherche de la paix
qu'il soit de plus inclusif possible
pierre Boisselet donc il voudrait c'est
ce qu'il dit moussafaki que finalement
il y ait le plus de gens possible autour
de la table que ça soit le plus inclusif
possible c'est pour parler qu'est-ce que
est-ce que ils ont une chance d'aboutir
d'abord et puis je vais bien sûr faire
réagir Patrick mouya mais pour parler de
Nairobi
je doute qu'il règle fondamentalement
la question parce que aujourd'hui le bon
un des problèmes c'est que le
gouvernement congolais ne veut pas
discuter avec le m3 en tout cas c'est
c'est les discussions sont dans
l'impasse à ce niveau là et je pense
d'ailleurs que le caractère inclusif
c'était c'est pour souligner selon
j'imagine Mouss qu'il faut réintégrer le
23 qui jusque là ne faisait plus partie
de de ce processus donc ça ce serait la
bonne démarche je ne sais pas si c'est
la bonne démarche elle semble faire
aujourd'hui
consensus au sein de la région
en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
le rapport de force militaire sur le
terrain
n'est pas en faveur de l'armée
congolaise depuis à peu près un mois
elle recule presque presque tous les
jours
et que donc le déploiement à la fois de
la Monusco ne permet pas d'équilibrer ce
rapport de force on a vu les troupes
kenyan commencé à arriver mais on parle
de 200 soldats pour l'instant il y en
aura peut-être 900 à terme mais je doute
que ça que ça permette
de battre de battre le M23 et donc voilà
dans cette situation là on voit mal quel
autre option que de discuter de discuter
Patrick mouya justement pourquoi est-ce
que vous ne souhaitez pas être discuter
avec le mouvement du M23 manifestement
ce que vient nous dire pierre Boisselet
c'est qu'il y a une sorte de consensus
autour de cela et Moustapha disait très
bien mais il y a des préalable parce que
lorsque nous avions adhéré à la
communauté de l'Afrique de l'Est il
était prévu qu'il y a un processus
politique dans ces processus
armés le seul groupe armé réfractaire
s'appelle se trouve être les M23 et
depuis ils ont gagné en violence comment
voulez-vous que nous puissions discuter
avec un mouvement qui est devenu
terroriste parce que tu as des familles
congolaises et déplaçant de centaines de
milliers et de congolais en même temps
ici il faut que le show soit dit de
manière claire les conditions pour nous
pour participer à quelqu'un en forme de
dialogue avec tous les groupes armés
parce qu'il faut pas penser que nous le
gouvernement nous allons négocier avec
les 1 23 bilatérales il est hors des
questions ils doivent être inclus comme
tous les groupes armées très traités à
égal des gars égales parce que les M23
sur terrain n'existe pas c'est l'armée
rwandaise qui fait des progrès en
espérant faire passer son agenda tout en
maintenant
sont connus les conditions sont connues
avant qu'on y arrive il faut arrêter
total le Guyane 23 des zones occupées il
se retire et à ce moment-là nous
pourrons évaluer les possibilités de
comment les discussions vont se faire
parce que le Président de la République
a déjà montré sa disponibilité le
gouvernement parce que nous voulons que
c'est très gentil soit pacifié et si
aujourd'hui il y a une force régionale
de tous les pays de l'Afrique de l'Est à
l'exception du Rwanda c'est justement
parce que les autres pays ont trouvé
pertinents les propositions qui ont été
faites par les présidents que le Rwanda
cesse de soutenir les M23 et les M23
serait tirent de toutes les localités
occupées nous pour pouvoir comment
discuter et régler les problèmes parce
que les règlements de ces problèmes là
nécessitera aussi beaucoup de sagesse et
beaucoup de temps et nous nous sommes
disposés parce que nous voulons que la
République démocratique du Congo soit en
paix sur toutes les tortues de santé
la question ce n'est pas d'être d'accord
pour un dialogue puisque c'est un
processus qui a déjà commencé mais ici
les actions notamment de l'Union
africaine doivent consister à demander
ou M23 de quitter les localités
occupées conquises grâce à l'armée
rwandaise pour que en ce moment-là nous
puissions évaluer comment les réintégrer
dans les processus global des dialogues
qui a déjà commencé un aérobie il faut
rappeler que le président
Ourou a été à Kinshasa était à Goma les
discussions préalables avec tous les
groupes armés se passent plutôt bien si
aujourd'hui il est à 23 s'est retiré de
toutes les localités occupées évidemment
nous serons à ce moment-là disposer de
voir comment le remettre dans les
formats s'ils ne le font pas parce que
manifestement ils le font pas
évident aussi ne les font pas c'est
parce que le roi de la ne veut pas que
cela c'est facile il faut qu'on soit en
mesure d'appeler les chats par son nom
vous avez suivi le secrétaire général
des Nations unies dire que les M23 se
comporte comme une armée on lui a posé
la question d'où vient les armes c'était
sur France 24 les armes viennent de
quelque part il y a le rapport du Groupe
d'experts des Nations Unies démontre par
A + B avec des images des drones pierre
boisselies qui avec vous sur le plateau
peut aussi confirmer c'est que je suis
en train de vous dire aujourd'hui perd
la pression suffisante
et quand même le président de la
Commission de l'Union africaine il dit
maintenant faut négocier y compris avec
le M23 mais on ne peut pas nous on ne
peut pas aller nous négocier avec un
groupe qui en deuil nos populations qui
déplacent des centaines de milliers
agréant d'abord sur le principe et
moussafaki et les autres ne seront pas à
contre ce que je dirais maintenant qui
doivent se retirer de localité
occupée avant toute idée de pouvoir
discuter ça ça doit être bien Aloïs
tiguerra est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est négociation en aérobie peuvent
aboutir
ben écoutez c'est négociations ne
peuvent pas aboutir aussi longtemps que
on essaie de Dénoyer en fait le vrai
problème de banyulsan du Congo comme un
problème errwandais c'est aussi un
problème congolais je peux rappeler
aussi à mes
batteurs qui avant que même ce régime du
rwandais n'existe et qui a chassé tous
les bagnoles de ma Sicile ou tout ce qui
confondu de la Conférence Nationale
Souveraine c'est là où les petits
enfants ont commencé à aérer un peu
partout dans la région donc pour moi il
y a un problème de fond le problème qui
a été l'argumentaire de base qui était
celui de cm2p EDM 23 reste toujours nous
avons de réfugiés
et ce problème existe depuis longtemps
je n'ai jamais vu aucun effort de la
part de gouvernement congolais devenu
quand même essayer de régler ce problème
une fois pour toute pour vider au moins
l'argumentaire
pour moi c'est pas normal qu'on croit
que en fait le problème on se focalise
sur le Rwanda mais un problème rien à
régler au Congo qu'en est-il de se
réfugier qui sont dans les cas au bout
au Rwanda et en Ouganda presque ils ont
depuis 28 ans c'était un problème réel
donc pour moi
l'argumentaire du sein de paix en 2004
jusqu'en 2009 celui de M23 en 2012 se
base toujours si cette existence de
réfugiés dans des cas à l'extérieur
pourquoi on ne peut pas vider cette
question une fois pour toute bien sûr il
y a des problèmes qui sont assez
difficiles parce que ils auraient pu
revenir comme tout le monde car tout à
l'heure son Excellence le Ministre
disait que c'était un problème qui est
terminé non c'est pas vrai moi je suis
je suis à Goma mais aussi je vis à
massissi comme tout le monde je vais
tout le temps je peux lui demander mais
qui fait taxer les populations massifis
c'est pas l'État congolais
on ne peut pas dire ces problèmes
n'existaient pas et tant que les délais
sont dans cette région je ne vois pas se
réfugier tous ceux qui sont au rwandais
à l'Ouganda revenu facilement donc il y
a des problèmes réels aussi qu'il faut
voir on ne peut pas escamoter prendre ce
qui est le plus facile et est-ce qu'à
moteur le problème de base qui est en
fait aussi problème de régler le
patrimoine Bayern du Congo c'était un
problème congolais aussi Patrick vous
lui répondez rapidement et je vais faire
réagir ensuite Roland courtier je crois
qu'il faut pas mélanger les choses
inexistent pas de problème de communauté
où tout est outil je préfère m'exprimer
en ces termes en République démocratique
du Congo parce que dans le gouvernement
nous avons un représentant un ministre
qui est tutti ou un ministre qui est où
tout il n'y a pas de problème en ces
termes-là et d'ailleurs il faut relire
la feuille de route de Luanda convenu
depuis le mois de juillet où nous
parlons de ces problématique de retour
de refusé comment pensez-vous qu'on peut
retourner les réfugiés dans la sérénité
lorsqu'il y a des violences du type
reconnaissant c'est des problèmes qui
existent depuis une vingtaine ou une
vingtaine d'années c'est des problèmes
qui ne doivent pas qui ne peuvent pas
être résolus par un claquement de bâton
magique aujourd'hui nous nous sommes
dans une stratégie parce que nous savons
que le Congo pour être grand nous ne
pouvons être grand que dans notre
diversité il y a pas de problème de
cohabitation en République démocratique
du Congo ça c'est les spectre de Kigali
qui est qui exécute pour justifier la
défense d'une communauté d'ailleurs
c'est une c'est un discours
ségrégationniste et donc nous nous
reconnaissons qui a un travail qui doit
être fait pour ces réfugiés qui sont
là-bas il y a un travail qui doit être
fait dans la lutte contre les effets de
l'air nous luttons nous-mêmes nous
combattons les effets et la France
régionale vient en plus pour continuer
de les combattre pour qu'elle ne soit
plus une menace d'abord pas pour le
Congolais ensuite pas pour le Rwanda
parce qu'elle est délire je rappelle il
tue d'abord le Congolais lorsqu'il
parlait des taxes qu'ils prélevaient ils
prélevait ça sur les dos de Congolais et
donc vous voyez que les défis sont
connus il faut pas virer la question
verte de communauté parce que pas
celle-là les populations qui souffrent
aujourd'hui parmi celles là il y a des
populations qui sont aussi rendophone
alors comment justifier vous une telle
attitude
également le reste du plateau
pardonnez-moi Patrick moyen Roland
Pourtier justement comment les mettre
d'accord les responsabilités sont
partagées ou ce n'est que le Rwanda il y
a d'autres pays j'ai vu qu'en marge de
du G20 en tout cas le secrétaire d'État
américain blinken s'est entretenu avec
son homologue rwandais Emmanuel Macron
aussi on a l'impression que la
communauté internationale fait un peu
pression sur le Rwanda aujourd'hui les
responsabilités sont forcément partagées
dans un conflit aussi ancien et aussi
complexe et on vient d'entendre
plusieurs intervenants qui nous donnent
vraiment à comprendre cette complexité
et alors
moi j'ai je suis pas très optimiste
parce que aucun des problèmes de fond
n'est résolu n'étant pas d'être résolu
ce qui est nouveau
problème économique le problème de la
terre qui est central tout ça n'est pas
résolu alors ce qui est nouveau c'est
peut-être l'intervention du Kenya de
cette nouvelle armée dans le cadre de la
Communauté Est Africaine c'est nouveau
peut-être peut-être et aussi en dessous
réussiront-ils alors que pendant 20 ans
la présence de l'ONU a été un énorme
fiasco mais cette armée justement n'a
pas n'empêche pas en tout cas les forces
du M23
elle est en cours de constitution je
crois qu'il peut l'armée de l'Afrique de
l'Est pour expliquer on peut inclure
donc le Kenya mais aussi j'ai vu le
Rwanda la Tanzanie le Soudan du Sud et
l'Ouganda et la RDC oui c'est ça mais
enfin là actuellement c'est
essentiellement autour du Kenya que
s'organise cette force armée et bon
faisons lui crédit on verra bien parce
qu'actuellement c'est extrêmement
difficile de comprendre de voir comment
on peut sortir de ce bourbier
il faut couper le nœud gordien mais
comment peut-être que cette situation
militaire peut être apportera des
éléments nouveaux pour faire avancer la
situation pour la débloquer Jean-Claude
oui comment sortir de ce moment
par autistique ça a été dit plusieurs
fois ça plusieurs décennies il va avoir
une armée d'interposition certains
veulent la mandat plus offensive
à
démembrer toute une armée qui est
surdotée qui est surdoté qui fonce sur
sur Goma il est bien dans pour
sauvegarder la souveraineté de la RDC
que c'est que la RDC le gouvernement de
la RDC demande au moins la cessation la
cessation des hostilités de la part du
M23 et voir se retirer pour continuer à
processus auquel il y a des oscillations
parfois même 23 dit oui dit non et
autres il y a des oscillations il y a
des interventions habiles et fortes et
de plus en plus forte de la France des
États-Unis de l'ONU de l'Union africaine
et le Kenya joue de plus en plus un rôle
clé et on va peut-être vers une une
résolution régionale mais qui doit pas
entamer la souveraineté de la RDC mais
comme ça a été dit à l'intérieur il y a
aussi des problèmes congolo congolais
qui doivent être réglés qui sont
structurels et qui ne date pas de
Phoenix Tshisekedi aujourd'hui qui sont
qui ont des racines qui ont plusieurs
décennies et une partie du Congo et pas
seulement celle-ci c'est senti un peu
ostracisé par rapport au pouvoir central
donc il y a plusieurs problèmes en même
temps et ben
voilà le défi de Monsieur Félix
Tshisekedi aujourd'hui et des pouvoirs
qui vont arriver après de régler
justement à travailler au renouveau de
la souveraineté pas seulement de la RDC
d'abord mais aussi reconstruire avec ses
voisins donc des relations de paix et de
cordialité et sur le plan géopolitique
géostratégique là aussi ça va être un
morceau français
de Roland courtier
j'aimerais bien avoir la réponse déjà
donc là le Kenya cette médiation kenyane
c'est armée est africaine ça c'est
positif alors je le sur le concept de la
de l'armée de la force régionale de
l'Afrique de l'Est je suis un peu
sceptique en revanche rejoindrai Roland
courtier pour dire que l'implication du
Kenya c'est un peu la nouveauté de cette
crise par rapport à il y a 10 ans par
exemple
je ne pense pas que la force kenyane en
tant que tel qu'on annonce de 900 hommes
permettent de résoudre à elle seule le
problème en revanche ce qu'il faut
espérer c'est que cette présence
donne à la médiation kenyane les leviers
politiques pour trouver des solutions
à cette crise Patrick
kenyane comment est-ce que vous y
répondez
il n'y a pas que la médiation kenyane il
y a la médiation qui a commencé autour
du président Lorenzo qui a été mandaté
par l'Union africaine je dois rappeler
ici que nous nous participons à tous les
processus diplomatiques parce que
justement pour nous on n'aurait jamais
dû retourner si bas parce que je dois
rappeler ici qu'à l'arrivée du président
tu sais qu'il y a la tête de la RDC il a
décidé d'harmoniser les relations qui
étaient derrière déjà tendues à l'époque
avec tous les pays voisins y compris les
Rwanda et il y avait même aucune
proposition des modèles de partenariat
économique que nous pouvons mettre en
place pour s'assurer que nous encadrons
les flux des collaborations d'échanges
qui existent entre nos populations
aujourd'hui que ce soit au niveau de
Luanda que ce soit au niveau Nairobi
nous attendons tous les signes sur le
terrain de signe en termes de retrait de
localité
occupée par la Juan
ce soir et les Cécile feu c'est ce qui a
été dit à Luanda en juillet c'est ce qui
a été dit en France septembre dernier
autour du président Macron à New York
c'est ce qui a été dit aussi à New York
tu sais qui a été répété encore dans la
résolution de la Francophonie parce
qu'on veut tout ce qui est séparer des
violences et aujourd'hui il appartiendra
au Rwanda qui soutient les 23 août tout
au moins qui s'est engagé dans tous les
créneaux diplomatiques à parler en 23 de
faire rapidement pour nous permettre
d'aller vers la paix mais ici je dois
rappeler que le Président de la
République à l'ancienne appelle à la
mobilisation générale aujourd'hui les
jeunes congolais massivement s'en rendre
dans l'armée aujourd'hui nous serons
très vigilants pour reprendre
l'expression de lui d'un codateurs tout
à l'heure pour défendre l'intégrité de
notre territoire qui est beaucoup
Patrick mouya d'avoir été avec nous
direct de Kinshasa Merci à VOUS allô oui
steggera vous étiez avec nous en directe
de Suède merci beaucoup pierre Boisselet
merci Roland Pourtier et puis merci
Jean-Claude Félix chicaya merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivi restez avec
nous sur France 24
[Musique]